so yes I saw a true-life I'm a financial
dominatrix last oh yeah and what it is
is bait there's this whole culture and
it really exists a lot more than I
thought it did yeah because every porn
star is able to find these dudes who
just get off like what they like to do
is just give porn stars money yeah so
we're way of feeling worthless and you
yeah like I like to feel that way but
sexually like you know a girl makes me
feel a certain way but not with my money
I mean I'll give money but not you know
I don't want that to be the whole thing
oh here's my money oh I'm gonna come
right it's gotta be something in there
half the time they're not being touched
like they're do it over the phone I've
had ever girls that say like she should
call somebody and say put money in my
account like PayPal or whatever and then
what they want is for the girl to call
them and yell at them saying I need more
money put more money in my account whoa
what's this thing on True Life it's just
one Asian guy who's just posing in front
of his webcam going tell me I'm a god
tell me I'm a god
now put money in my account bow down to
me Oh Asian guy an Asian guy doing it to
other guys and he made like four hundred
five hundred bucks over the course of 30
seconds I would do that too yeah I'd
love to be hands on those I'd love to be
a thin Dom why why would anybody be
paying you though cuz I'm just give me a
buckaroo if I say it all wrong put some
clams in my account pay it all it's cool
I want some samolians in there like
trying to get into it and so this isn't
this isn't what I yeah I want you
Bitcoin me much sweet attentional one
one girl that I talked to about it said
that her favorite thing to do was she
had this guy that would go see her and
especially when it rained she would
drive to the nearest ATM then make the
guy run across the street in the rain
get five thousand dollars out of the ATM
because it was the most he could take
out and then just hand it over to her
and that would be it but there wouldn't
be second time today she's paying her
for sex did she stay in the car she'd
say
the clothes gonna get wet that's what
happened he got wet your brother's hola
guess that's what the Rihanna song
should kick in but no it shouldn't be
not as today
do not let me show you how to do morning
radio uh-huh with this we have to do now
you got umbrella get that cued up I'm
gonna show you how this should have went
with sugar umbrella felon the [ __ ]
people how much they would have loved
that music cue I don't think so I don't
think so okay
Travis did tdawg has it in there it's in
the top box prepared and ready to go all
right so you know it was all rainy and
uh boy the guy's gonna get wet that's so
sweet let me come in on the umbrella
part nicely this is like this has now
become the radio version of waters world
like everybody just stops and the hawk
of the song Kissin
this is awful I think it's a good idea
it's not even like under it and just
like that the hook comes in and
everybody just stop talking cuz they're
like why the [ __ ] did that song just
start with one go back Tom Bella the
punch that you gotta anticipate you
anticipate when I'm in riff mode all
right here we go
you know it's what would happen with the
fin dum well so this is this woman
especially in the range you'd love to do
it in the rain would drive to the ATM
Eddie I [ __ ] what happened for the iPad
you know throw it yep why you can get
your car crashes out and I had to finish
my point yes she did stupid I got with
it and she would make him money across
the street in the rain to get money yeah
but if he crossed the street in the rain
is he gonna have his um god damn it you
know that's yeah hey all right well I
can't I can't I passed me can you stand
under my umbrella
no hey did you forget you can you stand
under my umbrella the line you're gonna
stop at hold on a minute did say he did
say that part of testing is to
anticipate the lowly
he's saying is turning into a calf
portion yeah he wants you anticipating
everything he's gonna say yeah and tough
to pee test debate in there and tough to
page that's what the test box is all
about
testa patient absolutely horrible he
tiny date he toughed it up he did he
kept me the whole thing I certainly did
that guy get I'm gonna try turn up right
I'm gonna show you how this is done this
is good this is a good way to figure
this stuff yeah on the end let the fans
see how this [ __ ] works right right
magic takes work show me all the sausage
is made that's right it's it's the Tefft
behind the curtain yeah yeah pay no
attention right so so you got this Dom
she's bringing the guy to the ATM it's
raining outside she's like I want you to
go across the street to that atm he's
stupid and get me $5,000 and he does he
runs over in the rain to the ATM gets
the $5,000 gives it back to her no sex
what a dick um yeah so I went wait was
it nice out no I already says it was
ready told you it was raining but if
it's raining I wonder if he had his for
you're supposed to hold on this heat
under right
you're supposed to anticipate the snort
right the snorts like the bottom push
yeah
then the umbrella kicks in right right
do we need to do it again one more quick
time okay so it's like guys it's writing
and the guy has to go to the ATM mmm you
know I wonder if he has his uh pump well
you know I'm holding my finger up is to
hang on
Oh see how holding my finger of a point
the door he doesn't want to hear your
excuses for not anticipate exactly
exactly not paying you to point up in
the sky I know where the Lord is let's
not use point okay oh you ready now
finally we would rebound finally half a
second you know waiting for am i
starting from this from the beginning of
the song oh right right we have to start
the whole thing a lot of [ __ ] ergot
yes okay not um hold on so the guy do
you want to take out five grand out of
an ATM yeah yeah that's the max you can
take out at this ATM but the guy did
in the rain did he yeah wait what for
what what for wait for what okay
Travis's fingers in the air you know
what was it
yes no no it was pointy I'm in the air
did you win yeah you were looking at
your dividers finger to check for wind
then Turk put his [ __ ] on it
Oh d-bag is in there just try to see
where I fit bosses okay I won't do it
again
no Doug was just asking about taking
five thousand I didn't know you could
take out that much
you can think my maximum was like five
hundred in my bank but this one is five
thousand dollars I don't know what part
of the world it was in I just know that
she made him go out uh while it was
raining you know so rain so yeah no rain
is oh why are you holding it no we are
not seeing idiot oh no I was inside
pointing with a microphone it's Jim was
holding the ear part of his phone to the
microphone but you put it on speaker as
if this bit well when I put it on
speakerphone it makes it come out of the
earpiece louder you know it doesn't that
was a mistake there's a speaker in the
phone that's what you hold up to the
microphone I need to hear it now yeah
well you didn't hear it here's the
problem I wasn't gonna do this but what
a negative lot of negative people in
this world and it gets tough for a lot
of people I'm HIV negative but in my
life um
I mean Charlie negative keeper in my
life I'm I'm a positive what was going
on in the background where word I was
looking for a cab this morning yeah you
were outside of your apartment how well
no I'm was hoping for a cab to drive to
the living room
you were saying us now I was standing in
my living room trying to flag a cab
would you hit just now a piece of glass
with a no sound it's [ __ ] awful your
whole area it's just a disaster joining
my crotch I don't know what's worse when
it works or when it doesn't worry I not
often you sing chip songs while waiting
for it a cab outside what he's supposed
to do any record it's always creating oh
thank you Doug very much I guess but
it's just so bad HIV negative yeah but
in his life he's positive no that's good
it's good it's really and I'm glad that
you shared that with us
absolutely I was something that we
hadn't me to blow the bit wasn't raining
when you we were doing that no but I
heard what was that spin dumping well
there was a thing the guy had to go out
to the ATM and it was is raining you
know so you got wet Oh wonderfully I
wonder if he had is hilarious oh my god
this is how you do radio boys this is
the radio show of the future this is it
that's right that's how you do radio no
wonder Doug made his choice
this is this is what he wanted to be a
part of the this imagine I come on
Eileen picking this over and maybe
changing your mind on this I might do a
video that's up with you on both shows
just talk about I think I might not do
this one anymore I'm not sure about this
one anymore I'm all bennington all the
time do you want to why do you want to
hear some of this dominatrix stuff yeah
I am interested in it it was I did a
whole hour thing about it I didn't know
they were like I guess it makes sense I
didn't know there were like young men
that were making it their lifestyles I
know I had only heard of women doing it
to two men that like to be abused but I
guess men like to be abused by men as
well go ahead Adrian you can play some
of
patreon hey was godly fee wait hold on
Adrian where's uh was rocky Oh Adrian
you heard that never heard the rocky
theme come in little gonna fly now ready
perfect how did you not anticipate that
I'm a Tufton idiot
yeah I had to get the rocky theme you
all right just for the future right in
case it comes up again Yeah right
Adrian's here all the time so yeah gotta
be ready for that one right behind me so
out of sight out of mind that's right
that's right you just let me know when
you have that when you have that in the
test box and you should really you know
if you're going to properly anticipate
every morning you should be going
through a list of songs that might be
mentioned and having them ready to go so
you know and obviously umbrella and the
theme from Rocky would both be on that
list
umbrella depending on the weather that's
well it's not raining outside so this
together all right we're doing the
stories on the prep sheet anyway
Adrian Adrian where's uh where's uh
Paulie mr. Gaza and rocky stupid let the
whole song play this really is waters
world of radio this is also [ __ ] you
kidding me this is how you're doing you
think so
absolutely okay okay how does the test
box feel about the way the shows going
love it it's terrible do you think
sounds that good is it like you like to
stay busy yeah yes I'm like hey all of a
sudden if their challenge is mine that's
his problem not first of all this isn't
challenging anybody's mind
second of all that was flawless testing
test problem in there is a work ethic
yeah absolutely he does is busy putting
his finger up in the air and lollygaggin
right and lollipops like Bob said
lollipops okay let's hear let's hear
some of this financial dominatrix stuff
then are you paying Paul ready so this
is okay this is the geyser this sorry
he's not a bad-looking guy though he's
got his feet out
at least he's I thought it was just some
old Asian guy question he was an
they said he was a young asian guy I
didn't pay attention you thought you
just getting confused all the Jesse
Watters stuff and his guys hairdo though
he has hair like somebody who's afraid
of losing their hair so they comb it
forward right here's evildea they're
trying to look younger and it fails
miserably with the original Justin
Bieber cut
I love the beeps I know you do I know
you do hey like us know stuff singing
about fondue like an adult like when he
was a boy he did baby baby
that's your favorite or I'd love one
baby oh Jesus so this is the Asian guy
talking to another guy on skype and he's
got his feet out
he's showing he's showing the guy on
skype his feet yeah on a serve and
worship oh he's trying to lick him he's
licking a webcam iPad Ozzie Ozzie Harbor
Washington
I'd like you to worship my face get on
your knees mmm are you good
I signed me $30 you can smell my arse
which if I see became a fin down would
you take in my eyes a second hey Aziz
you hold up master of reality pull your
little [ __ ] out and send me some money
okay you're just licking your webcampus
a mailing Asiata yes I need yes I would
I'm gonna string children to the grave
yes I would move it back just a little
bit Adrian as you restart for Washington
alpha Finn Dom cash master - master
gonna take you on a little adventure
you're gonna be my human a champ
he's blindfolding a guy that's Jerry in
person alleged one that accepts cash
from a submissive
someone that wants to serve me and have
me as their Idol see he just wants the
guy to an ATM machine is my natural I'm
glad it wasn't raining oh my god can you
imagine if it was raining and he has on
his uh
uh eyepiece and all of a sudden he's out
in the rain he's got the eyepiece he
feels the raindrops right and he says to
himself I sure wish I had my oh man
Oh smooth no it isn't I don't go like
that it's okay
smooth new my right or wrong
smooth I can't believe you came into
radio as an outsider yes I did seven how
many years ago 15 years ago I would say
now it's you know how long it's been 15
years ago on a second know if left had
any [ __ ] clue back there he'd clues
Club Amana Mexican radio a radio no no
don't do it don't do it who's got that
you know you guys know why that should
man on the sound clip Adrian's got the
true-life clip we don't need the Mexican
radio clip you have been in radio for 15
years and have picked up zero instincts
it's not true you have no radio
abilities whatsoever you have not
learned to broadcast at all this is
another song by the way the chip likes
the Mexican radio show he texted me yeah
I don't remember that little anza don't
remember really what was it instead of
radio it's Pekka again Decker all oh
it's not fine no it's not at all no I
didn't want to hear this I mean I love
you I wouldn't haven't heard this to the
limit
yeah I don't want to hear it at all we
don't set this the new direction
you know we'd have to hear that you're
spoiling it we just got to hear the one
part Mexican radio just that part who
remembers this so who doesn't every
worst day I think of in the morning
how much old oh he's got a Jim Norton
eye thing going a little ight which on
the left eye Travis what's your level of
familiarity with this song zero to one
exactly this isn't this is a tile he
just described you and Sam on a dating
site
Eddie don't stop it wasn't working
no we're going back to Finn Dom's yatta
all right people I like people to see
the magic being created though yeah I
know you do but there's no magic being
created um let's go back to let's go
back to Ozzie when we asking about me no
Adrian you should be ready then I would
stop hitting your [ __ ] tooth why
nobody likes that you don't like salads
Andre do so have your paws I'm gonna do
that nobody like it's gross it is go
ropes yeah you got the teeth tamper
nothing you're not doing it when it was
my childhood washes down the hall what
it's like what it's quiet on the radio
they don't hear it boys the constant
noise you're saying management likes the
direction of your teeth tapping yes bat
even four out of five dentists surveyed
like the direction of the shell Aragon
what I was saying was that you guys need
more musical beds you during the show
Isaac you Jim how long have you been a
part of broadcasting well uh it's been
about I'd say since about 2000 I've been
performing on
okay she says it's like Dicky what's his
name Dickie good Mickey shotgun wound to
the head Jack's a chainsaw and that's
exactly where I'm headed if you don't
stop this nonsense you sure you didn't
start it 1999 I'm not Mexican radio no
prints when I was prints that was
obvious that was very very awkward how
about whatever somebody dies we could
play when doves cry yeah obviously
obviously who died anybody die I don't
know this is the most recent celebrity
death hmm or should we just go with
Robert Kelly's dog before the show
Adrian tempted me we're talking about
Doris Roberts she's dead when did she
die though a few months ago I met her
like a week before she died I'm there a
week after week s I know I'm over you
Parker you are I missed it you are sorry
and we talked to Gary Marshall very
shortly before before he passed sure oh
yeah I regret why I actually I had a
weird foreshadowing to you guys we were
off the air but as usual he took my
jacket by action yes I kicked him in the
back and I hope to die let's get to the
let's get to the end of the fin Dom I
don't hold on can wait for my [ __ ] to go
down first we are good worshipping on
that's my eyes my jawline my personality
is one that really rocks and kills it
really rocks it and kills it yeah like
parkour Thai fans just happened to be
gay males then they say my hardcore Shia
fans he did go back well he must be a
great Dom hardcore - I want you to look
I want you to I toes my foot worship
love it bark or die fans just hardcore
diamonds I want to hit wish up a
straight alpha male this came in its
brand new coffee maker I've had Wow
laughs the advantages is just Lavery
yeah what's another Dom has coffee
breath I want you to send me send your
God a coffee me yeah Oh worship my feet
while I drink Sanka
unsexy money was probably in the dudes
but before he gave it to him oh it
definitely why not money is so dirty my
mother tell me don't put money don't
make money no it's better for spending
that's right oh yeah once again mr. Q
don't don't do the cute wiggle it we're
on it we're just trying to start an mony
mony that sounds terrible
alright get back to his Audi's ATM cards
that were given to me from I personally
used to go out to bars clubs
you name it sky's the limit growing up I
was a dog like a couple months old from
what the twenties a little boy air force
so we travel to lock that one military
brat within would you be have always
been would you send him money if he's
just when he was just a little boy if it
was like a three-year-old Finn dumb
friend I'm sure you send them I buy
yourself a rattle Chaka Chaka Chaka
should I go to cook not go can I have
your shoes bronzed Oh Chris it's old
Boise yeah I'm gonna hang in my main man
what are you gonna bronze him with I'm
gonna shellacque your feet Oh gross mr.
ha guess what's on his feet that's foot
shellacking oil
I guess not oil
Gary Estefan on your feet right Adrian
Travis is a little plain knowing wise it
y'all were used to play the underwear
undie flip and I shall like his feet is
that true Travis that should happen I
don't know I blocked a lot of things oh
god damn it no wonder your mom life yeah
she was busy on the fly weird game there
was it yeah I distract her every time
she come in a house I'd frisbee a matzo
down the hallway you see Doug got a
field dog in he gets funny out of
context oh absolutely absolutely but the
reason it's even funny because in real
life Travis's mother left him and his
entire family for a wrap
for a rabbi with no sort of warning and
stop talking to them forever she just
left the family yeah so that's what Jim
was making fun of you have it's also
known as comedy gold that's a funny
story
right yeah right she'd say yeah mr. Hogg
s what are you doing with my little son
/ daughter to frisbee it down the hall
instant distraction
oh yeah she'd run it right at it
sometimes she'd bang a head into the
door not even looking good all right 30
more seconds been that wild child well
oh my god what am i doing in this video
this is a bad man I don't we just walk
it around
chubbie been at least this guy's getting
everything he is dirty sneakers I went
to a club and oh ah ah someone wanted
which it is tedious Mike Oh Mike's a
guide for it this is where the fun
begins oh my god
the Nagel kid yeah yeah and I just
flipped it to my liking
that was just a power trip from there oh
my god oh he's wrapping up in cellophane
his entire body and dick why would you
want to wrap a guy up in cellophane I
feel it's humiliating
yeah yes for fun don't you yeah I don't
know why also I'm gonna tell you this
though d-bag is very lucky that Thomas
Haden Church is on his way in because
otherwise it would have been naked d-bag
in cellophane day let's see that we
should do that should wrap them with a
cellophane I'd love to them pushing on
with that yeah test be good how it is
doubted out his d-bag in there feel
about being wrapped up naked in
cellophane
what made you even think of that just
because we were just watching a guy get
wrapped up in something you think my
torso would look good wrapped up and I
think so I didn't this guy wrap it up
nice and tight you know you've talked to
us before you have some torso issues
I wouldn't go completely naked though
that's crazy but we'll do underwear
found bikini I don't know there you go
yes we'll get some european-cut
underwear for you no problem